now as we talk about boosters there's a
growing pushback this morning over some
efforts to vaccinate workers the head of
chicago's police union says that half
that's right half the department could
be pulled off the force over vaccine
mandates there nancy chen is in chicago
nancy good morning
nate good morning to you in an emergency
hearing on friday a judge temporarily
banned the head of the local police
union from encouraging officers to defy
vaccine requirements that was just hours
before a deadline for officers to submit
their status
those who refused could face
consequences
each of us should be able to make a
personal choice for our health concerns
and not have the government dictate what
that looks like to them
before the ruling chicago fraternal
order of police president john
cantonzara pushed police to ignore last
friday's deadline to report their
vaccine status and predicted if the
city's new mandate is enforced thousands
of officers will be off the job the
policy requires all city employees to be
fully vaccinated now workers can be
unvaccinated through the end of the year
if they undergo regular testing those
who don't will face consequences like
unpaid leave
no one should ruin their career over
saying yes or no on a portal that hasn't
happened yet but the fight is escalating
with the union suing the city and the
city suing the union and its leader what
we've seen from
the fraternal order police in particular
leadership is a lot of misinformation a
lot of half truths and frankly flat out
lies in order to induce an insurrection
and we're not having that the city's
lawsuit claims if followed canton
sarah's orders would result in an
unlawful and dangerous work stoppage
that would endanger the entire city as
well as his own membership the turmoil
comes as 476
officers across the country have died of
covet so far tragically in the past two
years
covert 19 has caused more deaths in the
line of duty
than all the other causes combined
similar fights over vaccine mandates are
playing out in other cities like san
francisco and seattle where detectives
are being sent to emergency calls
because of a shortage of patrol officers
and back here in chicago police are now
restricting time off for officers until
further notice it's not clear if that's
related to the mandate but some wonder
if it's to prepare for a possible staff
shortage however the mayor assures
chicagoans that they should not be
worried about their safety and that they
have contingency plans gail
nancy thank you very much